hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here to finally
catch up with jiu-jitsu
exploring the itadore extermination arc
as well as the beginning of something
that seems insanely promising
with the curling game of which there are
only like three
chapters so far but holy crap there's a
lot packed into them just as i would
like to pack a lot into you
a lot of jiu-jitsu kaisen that is so use
what hands you have to hit the subscribe
button for the new world review thus
resulting in consistent injections of
jiu jitsu madness
administered straight into your youtube
feed i really love this series and i am
100 planning on continuing to make as
many videos on it as you people are keen
to watch but let's begin with the story
extermination this short arc has a very
simple premise which can be summed up
entirely in one word
that word being consequences the events
of shibuya have completely changed the
course of the series and perhaps even
the world
organizations are in turmoil people have
lost their lives and our characters are
pretty profoundly scarred some
quite literally hello marky nice to see
you but i actually think one of my
favorite aspects of this arc is
right at the beginning akitami opens up
with a shot of japan at night and a
literal void surrounding shibuya very
simple but very effective in conveying
the seriousness of the situation it's
like the aftermath
of a natural disaster and the following
pages packed with speech bubbles from
disembodied voices
is a great way of getting across the
sheer chaos within this aftermath and i
like this because aftermath is not
something explored
too deeply within many shonen series
it's more of an inconvenient reality
that we just skip over even the ones i
love most like say one piece
are very matter of fact about aftermaths
no matter how destructive the art climax
has been
a day or two later everyone and
everything is pretty much okay which is
fine because that's the feel-good nature
that a series like one piece goes for so
in a weird way this bitter bitter pill
from akutami is actually
kind of a treat because our characters
are they are nowhere near okay i
mentioned maki before because she's a
pretty good example
she is alive however her design has now
forever changed with this pretty insane
scarring and now sporting short hair
assumingly because a lot of it got burnt
off not all of it but some of it
interesting how fireworks and as twisted
as it sounds i really appreciate this
when bad things happen to characters
they should carry that experience with
them whether that be mentally or
physically or both and many authors
don't have the guts to make that sort of
change especially to a very marketable
attractive female character of course
maki isn't the only one inumaki
apparently lost an arm due to sukuna
related reasons which is pretty big and
we haven't seen todo yet but i imagine
that his injury is rather permanent as
well and for those who did come out
physically unscathed like yuji
well he's carrying a hell of a lot of
trauma but the great advantage is that
all of this suffering and defeat will be
carried with us going forward like even
though we're in a completely new arc we
don't have to start building the drama
from zero because our main bad guy has
already very much incurred our wrath
here like i want ghetto or noritoshikamo
what's his new name kenjaku
doesn't matter the guy i have a profound
desire to see him fall because of what
he's done to all of these characters
that i love and if everyone was just
okay then i don't think that would be
the case meanwhile there are a series of
gigantic revelations during this very
short time the first of which is the
return of utah seeing him emerge to
confront yuji was an
interesting experience because it was
like seeing two main characters from
different series meet in some sort of
crossover event and there's a lot of
great stuff here in fact akutami even
goes to the trouble of verbally pointing
out how yuta and yuji are basically
exact opposites in terms of ability one
a physical powerhouse with minimal
cursed energy and the other a physically
standard specimen with nyon infinite
cursed energy even more than gojo
apparently so it was really fun yet
excruciating to see this clash because
as well as yuji did
everything i know from the prequel was
telling me that this was not someone
that yuji had any hope of overcoming
whatsoever even in the event that sukuna
took control of his body yuta's
existence is just that ridiculous
and i don't know if it matters i mean it
probably does we still know very little
about sukuna's true depth of power but
basically alarm bells were going off in
my head throughout this entire fight
especially because rika is still in play
very intriguing
since she disappeared in the prequel to
the best of my memory so maybe that's
not her but like another manifestation
of a thing with her name i don't know
once again doesn't matter the very
existence of rika is potentially as
world-breaking as having gojo around and
there was also a nice bit of irony with
yuta being appointed yuji's executioner
since they both began their jujut's
career under the exact same scenario but
of course everything makes sense in the
end with the twist that yuta was an ally
all along and i love that he had to go
so far as to make a binding vow to
actually
kill yuji that was a very nice touch and
that comes back to consequences yuji's
execution was merely one of a series of
mandates set by the high council of
jujutsu dudebras
the one i find most interesting is that
gojo has been classified as an
accomplice of ghetto and it is now a
crime to unseal him which makes all the
sense in the world in terms of
sorcerific politics gojo is an absolute
pain so him being sealed is very much a
gift to these guys even if it comes at
the cost of
what was the number they said like 10
million cursed spirits being released
into this world it was quite a lot oh
and even the principle of jujutsukai was
sentenced to death which was quite
surprising and it reminded me that we've
seen
annoyingly little of him in the entire
series so far i would love to know more
about him and i hope that this degree
makes him a bit more active in the
series and consequences only continue
because to add on to the list of actual
deaths during shibuya we have now beetos
and in who honestly if there was one
person who was going to survive jojo's
assault i would have thought it would be
him in retrospect his technical purpose
during shibuya was fantastic as he was a
lot of fun to watch and his death
forever changes how we look at the zenin
clan which is now floating in just as
much chaos as the jujutsu administrators
and japan at large also another big
twist here congratulations fushiguru it
seems you are now the head of the
zenning clan
probably the one person who didn't want
it but it continues the fushiguro hype
train because i'm assuming this decision
was made because he is the only one with
the potential to rival the stability
that goja represented and the most
important new character to spawn from
all of this
and in stuff is now yeah who is uh he's
a prick isn't he and he's very well
matched against cho so a nice
juxtaposition there akitami having him
fight with a character who prioritizes
care for family members above all else i
don't have any particularly strong
feelings about nalia i mean it was nice
to see him get beaten up and he added a
fun third-party element to the whole
extermination arc but otherwise
right now i just don't care i'm sure
he'll be fun in the future back to chozo
though this is where arguably the
biggest of revelations of the art comes
from because he inquires as to the
hypothesis of yuji's father having a
scarred forehead
heavily implying that they are indeed
legit brothers
somehow which led to a crazy small
flashback where in fact it was yuji's
mother who had the scars i guess
implying that yuji himself was created
by noritoshikamo for
reasons to be revealed at some stage and
i guess that begs the question
was toto also created in this way hence
all the brotherly bonds now before you
comment down below with the thing i've
seen a billion times now
i have read some comments at this point
and a lot of people are very quick to
inform me that there is apparently no
connection between cho so and the total
incident
akutami has stated in an interview that
they both see memories that never
existed for different reasons and it
isn't foreshadowing for any kind of
technique
curse technique i should say and to that
i say
i don't know if i believe you author
there is definitely a connection there
is no way that an author is painfully
thought
out as akhitami just accidentally uses
the same left field device again with
the exact same dialogue and everything
and when you think about it the
statement is very vague all akitami says
is that it's not foreshadowing for a
curse technique that doesn't mean that
there is no connection it just means
that the connection is something else
so we'll see about that i suppose big
big news though is that yuji actually
seems to have accepted cho so as a
brother there was this really sweet
moment where he tells everyone to just
you know think of choso as my older
brother
and also a very nice badass moment of
chozo claiming to be the eldest of 10
siblings which is obviously the 9 death
paintings
plus yuji i like that connection a lot
it was unexpected and it makes the other
two death paintings or ever so much more
tragic to think back on
poor poor paintings and i guess that
brings us to the idea of the culling
game i mean it doesn't really that was a
terrible transition but we're here now
and we're going to deal with it now this
is where things go a bit off the rails
because the overall plan of not
ghetto is fairly complex in a kind of
neon genesis sort of way electing to
merge
i think all of humankind would tengen
thus forcing evolution
in fact when i think about it it's
almost a word-for-word explanation of
the human instrumentality project from
the evangelion which on its own has
significantly raised the stakes of this
series to something of an apocalyptic
rapture
having brought him up tengen yeah
so when i last spoke about tengen i
compared him to the idea of an eldritch
horror you know cthulhu sort of stuff
something that is better left unseen
because no visual depiction
could do the legend of this guy justice
and i stand by that because
what the hell is this i burst out
laughing when i saw him for the first
time and i had a lot of trouble taking
anything he said seriously which is a
problem because he said a lot of serious
things
i don't know where people at large stand
on this but right now i
think it was a mistake to depict
tenganador because while i can mock his
design all i want
i'm 99 confident that there is no design
that would have satisfied me to his
credit akatami does address the design
with yuji basically reacting like i did
and it's played for some nice lofts with
a sly smile from tengen so akutami is
very aware of what he's done and that's
just a choice i'm going to have to live
with i do hope there's more to tangen
than just looking like an
oversized sperm though gotta be honest
lots of important information here
though like yet another name for not
ghetto which i think i'll be converting
to from here on out
being kenjaku which sure right now
it probably sounds a lot better in
japanese because you get the meaning
behind it but
to me it's just like random name what
interests me far more are the rules set
out for the culling game
if you've been listening to me ramble
about things for any amount of time then
you will know that i am a pretty big fan
of death games especially while written
ones with intriguing rules
and that's why i am so excited about the
future of jujitsu kaisen because these
rules are wonderfully hype especially
the one where the contestants who have
accrued a certain amount of points can
make a new
rule that little thing is brilliant
because as much as i love them one issue
that can arise with death games is
stagnation because it's hard to write
plot twists with such clear and
unbreakable sets of rules so the idea
that the culling game is going to evolve
over time is great because that will
make it nigh on impossible to predict at
any given stage i'm also very excited to
meet the other contestants at the time
of writing this we've been briefly
introduced to two
count em two new characters one being
hanakurasu the
1000 year old angel sorcerer and the one
who actually interests me
a lot more being the crappy comedian
fumihiko takaba mainly because he is
just so out of place this juxtaposition
is wild in one chapter we see this
revered 1000 year old sorcerer and in
the very next we are introduced to this
loser comedian
and they're playing the same game which
obviously sets my mind a light thinking
about what this guy could possibly be
capable of and not just that but the
potential of future contestants if i had
to bet right now i'd say the culling
game is set up to be quite an extended
arc should be your length perhaps even
longer so i'm very keen to see how many
of these third-party figures that we're
introduced to
each with their own unique motivations
and skill sets or perhaps motivations
and no skill sets like mr comedian but
really i don't see how this could be a
shorter arc with all the factors
surrounding the game be it the time
length rules a couple of which seem to
emphasize the number 19 a lot
don't know if that has any deeper
meaning that i just completely miss in
english there's also the complication of
additional rules the fact that this
really probably does require a
staggering amount of characters to
satisfyingly play out i mean it's not
much of a world-changing culling game if
only a handful of contenders show up
given that sorcerer is worth like five
points each man you need to kill like 20
sorcerers to do the rule changing thing
so we're gonna have a lot of people and
that's your sorcerer's like the
non-sorcerers are worth one point
and then there's the other complication
of kenjaku not actually being the game
master and that is one of my favorite
pieces of information that makes this
whole game idea so much more fascinating
than bad guy does
bad things with bad bad game especially
if the game master is actually impartial
which we're led to believe they will be
due to a series of binding vows required
to construct the game in the first place
and another miscellaneous thing we still
don't know what happened to kugisaki
i feel like it's implied by akutami that
even if she is alive she's not at all in
a good way but the information is
proving very evasive because yuji
understands whatever fushiguro's eyes
were telling him and obviously that's
deliberately designed to not let us know
and i have no idea when we'll find out
but the award for quote of the chapter
does also go to fushiguro he said
something i think epitomizes jujutsu
kaisen as a whole which was we aren't
heroes fighting for justice
and jiu jitsu sorcerers and i think
we've heard something similar before
from
maybe gojo or someone but i love that
it's a theme that gets hammered home
fairly frequently but it's always a nice
reminder that no we're not out to save
the world
or do good because you know that's the
thing to do we are condemned
sorcerers condemn sorcerers who have
elected to live in a very special hell
where the concept of good and bad is
very much not
black and white and that's why i am not
done talking about jejutsu kaisen this
has been a pretty amazing experience and
i look forward to joining the weekly
grind with everyone else but that pretty
much does it for this blind review
series of jujutsukai sen and what do you
guys think please do leave your thoughts
in the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more jiu jitsu sorcery then please
do check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel for very
maybe regular jude's kaiser morbidity
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time